Actors have to constantly ponder their next
moves.
What if a role turns out to be nothing like
they thought?
Can they speak openly about regret?
If they do, will they ever work again?
The following TV actors regretted some aspect
of their work—a poorly shot scene, a show
they wish had gone differently, a job they
wouldn't take if they had to do it over again—and
admitted their disappointment later on.
In the weeds
Mary-Louise Parker has filmed a number of
steamy scenes in her long career, and more
than one in her role as Nancy Botwin on Showtime's
Weeds.
"Worked for me so far."
But for one 2008 episode, Parker shot a revealing
bathtub scene we can't show here, that she
later wished she could take back.
She told More magazine:
"I fought with the director about it, and
now I'm bitter.
[...] I wish I hadn’t done that.
I was goaded into it."
She later clarified that the "fight" was really
just a creative discussion, and that she's
totally comfortable being in her birthday
suit on camera and off, saying,
"I was talking about that scene as an example
of something I didn't love as much when I
saw it."
Dark turn
Devon Gummersall is best known for playing
Brian Krakow, the big-haired, Angela Chase-obsessed
nerd on the short-lived '90s drama My So-Called
Life.
"Finally: Ane rection from actual physical
contact."
Gummersall would go on to portray Stevie Wolcott
on Mad Men, but before he was Peggy Olson's
blind date, he played a very bad dude named
Zach on the Keri Russell-led WB serial Felicity.
At the time, Gummersall was into the role
because it was such a departure from previous
characters.
In retrospect, he later told Cosmopolitan
he sees it as a mistake.
"I loved being on the show, but in the end,
I realized that it was sort of a mistake to
do that kind of a storyline.
I would have much rather been on the show
more long-term and done something that didn't
have to end in such a bad way."
Unhealthy Minds
Mandy Patinkin, who played Agent Jason Gideon
on CBS's Criminal Minds for two seasons, quit
the procedural in 2007 after not attending
a table read.
Patinkin later said he regretted making the
decision to do the show in the first place,
due to its graphic and violent nature.
Patinkin told New York Magazine in 2012:
"It was very destructive to my soul and my
personality."
Patinkin, who now plays Saul on Showtime's
Homeland, explained what he sees as the difference
between the two shows.
Of Homeland, which itself isn't without violence,
Patinkin said,
"It asks why there's a need for violence in
the first place."
Friends like these
For five episodes in 1999, Friends saw the
addition of Janine, played by model Elle Macpherson,
who moved into Joey's apartment and briefly
became his love interest after Chandler moved
across the hall to live with Monica.
Most actors would have killed to extend their
arc on the wildly popular show, but Macpherson
turned down the opportunity, saying that had
she known the show would have such staying
power, she wouldn't have taken the job in
the first place.
"If I'd known how important it was in the
U.S. or how long it would be on TV, I may
not have chosen to do it."
While the show proved career-making for Macpherson's
castmates, she's spent the last 20 years reminding
people she had a career before—and after—Janine.
O.C. overkill
Mischa Barton played Marissa Cooper on Fox's
The O.C., a drama about beautiful, wealthy
teens that ran for four seasons—although
Cooper was written off in a car accident in
the show at the end of season 3.
Since leaving the show, Barton has been open
about her regrets, telling the UK's Metro
in 2014:
"It's something I came so close to not doing.
I had a really great thing with film.
People say be grateful for what you have but
it's certainly not the kind of thing I was
expecting it to be."
The O.C. plunged all of its young stars into
the spotlight, which Barton particularly resented.
"I just like to be seen for the hard-working
actress that I am and not for a bunch of extraneous
press."
Community feud
After being out of the entertainment spotlight
for years, Chevy Chase returned to television
in 2009 as part of NBC's Community.
In 2013, during the critically lauded but
perennially ratings-starved show's fourth
season, Chase left, calling his decision to
join the cast "a big mistake," citing the
exhaustion of doing long television hours
and calling sitcoms, quote, "the lowest form
of television."
Chase and the show's creator, Dan Harmon,
were also engaged in a well-documented feud.
"Ok, thanks for coming.
Bye bye!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!